school system they don't want us to
learn about money because they just want
to pump out good employees that do what
they're told I mean if you look at
school it's opposite of what it takes to
be successful in real life don't make a
mistake do as you're told take take
tests by yourself oh there's only one
right answer no there's tons of answers
to a problem I don't think there's like
an Overlord that like doesn't want
people to learn about money they
probably couldn't get a curriculum about
money because they couldn't agree on
what was the right way to do it and the
point of like there's more than one
right answer it's true it just makes it
very hard to grade I think there's just
inherent infrastructure issues that make
many of the lessons of Life difficult to
teach not to say that they're impossible
but I think there would have to be an
overhaul of the entire school system
which I hope Ai and some of the
personalized education things that are
coming out right now could pave the way
for